so I'm here with David Coleman who's the
president of the College Board and we
have a pretty big announcement slash
collaboration together tell us more
about what we're doing David
I'm super excited because today the
College Board is announcing a broader
and renewed commitment to delivering
opportunity which means going beyond an
assessment itself to making sure kids
take advantage of the opportunities they
earned but also to dare to take
seriously the corruptions that have
arisen around the exam process what I
mean is the percentage the perception
that costly test preparation has made
the ground on even and this examined its
finest should be about merit it should
be about hard work that's equally
available to all and there is no better
statement of world-class high quality
stuff for all than partnering with Khan
Academy to provide free SAT test
preparation for the world which is what
we commit to today and I just want to
you know I guess doubly underlining and
said I mean we all remember when we took
the SAT there's you know there are some
folks taking these these fairly costly
prep courses on the you know basically
the idea that it it might help them and
on maybe on the margin it did help them
and you know what what we're saying
together is you know that ability to pay
for that should not be a factor anymore
you're exactly right and and what should
be a factor is the quality of your
practice and your command of mathematics
for example which which is you know to
command a few things well so as we
redesign the exam we're allowing kids to
really focus on the math that matters
most it's the most flexible and widely
used and the only way to gain gain real
command of that is through practice and
and what I'm really excited about you
know when we first started talking about
this this isn't just you know hey Kahn
Academy why don't you just try to see
what you can do and make some test prep
materials it's really about a very close
collaboration where we work together not
and not just to make a hey you know if
you can't afford something here's
something nice but to make something
truly world-class so that we can make
something that's as good or better than
any of the high cost courses or
materials but do it for free that's
exactly our shared aspiration and we
want to go beyond now test preparation
to really preparing kids for an
understanding and skill and fluency with
math and literacy that allows them to
encounter a wide range of problems with
confidence and I think that's where
we're very aligned
one thing even when my my cousins or
even a lot of my friends were taking the
SAT you know they would take these
courses say oh when in doubt guess see
and this answer and I was and I would
always tell people no if you really
understand the underlying mathematics or
the underlying grammar you don't have to
play these games that the answers will
will will come to you and so the way
we're going to tackle this isn't about
kind of gaming the system it's really
about getting those core fundamental
ideas so not only will you do well on
the SAT and other tasks you'll actually
be prepared for college and the
redesigned SAT makes that clearer than
ever that it's no longer about tricks
guessing is not penalized you put your
best answer forward we're talking about
reading with attention to evidence when
you read we're talking about a core of
math that is flexible as you say for the
future
so it's much less about tricks about
mysterious things than an open exam that
celebrates good work and the work you've
done in your high school well all of us
the whole team here at Khan Academy and
you know we've always been all about the
student helping the student kind of take
control of their learning and you know
we're honored that that you guys would
work with us on this you know once again
very close partnership to make not just
a you know nice to have tool for
students but a really interactive deep
experience that is as good as or frankly
I think it's going to be much better
than anything else out know to be clear
this will be the only place in the world
and free to the world besides on our own
website that students will be able to
encounter materials for the exam that
are in surely focused on the core of the
math and the literacy that matters most
we will partner with the Khan Academy to
ensure the quality and validity of every
item every practice item and make sure
that this work we do together is of the
highest quality and there'll be no other
such partnerships so I think it can be
the very best there is super-exciting
thank you